the morale their mouthpieces I don't  have any officer saying this action  should not have been taken against this  individual this officer I'm getting the  complete opposite response chief thank  you for being quick and decisive this is  going to help heal us  the officers are hurting I've been out  there on patrol and since this occurred  and it's the officer they come up and  hug and it's very emotional because the  officers they try too hard every day to  try to make this city better I likened  it yesterday to some of our officers  that are out there every weekend and  most weeknights that that they're out  there trying to build these  relationships and I likened it to a  bunch of ants building an anthill and  then somebody comes with the hose and  washes it away they just have to start  from scratch and build over I think  that's going to be all thank you